on va revenir sur les manifestations
contre le racisme aux états unis avec
l'historien donald cuccioletta chercheur
associé à la chaire raoul dandurand
l'uqam
mais ses coutures et un bon soir bonjour
de la bougie quel regard vous portez sur
ce mouvement de colère aux états unis a
longtemps qu'on n'a pas vu une telle
mobilisation veut semble-t-il mais il
est toujours été là l'itu routier
xian'an en train de s'organiser
c'est beaucoup monsieur trump a raison
quand il dit la gauche américaine
beaucoup de ces noirs là sont membres de
différents groupes de gauche aux états
unis et aussi tous ceux qui lui tiennent
présentement dans les différentes villes
à travers le pays
les latines et qu'est-ce qu'on les
appelle maintenant sont un peu plus les
hispanophones il s'appelle latine x plus
la question des jeunes bilingues ici
qu'il suggère on te voit finalement
cette coalition qui reprennent que moi
j'ai vu passer dans des années 60
donc on peut faire le parallèle qui
s'est passé années 70 ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui particulièrement à
minneapolis même ici dans 30 villes
amies donc ça veut dire une amertume
profonde du goût de la communauté
africaine américaine
ça fait longtemps qu'on les traite comme
des citoyens de seconde zone
cephalon temps aussi que la police en
général dénis les arrête pour n'importe
quoi
c'est aussi à chaque fois qu'il ya
quelque chose qui se passe dans un
quartier c'est la faute des noirs on va
les arrêter c'est vraiment arbitraire on
utilise les fusils turin on sait le
nombre de noirs qui sont fait assassiner
par la police dans différentes villes
battement de cils dont le boulaire
nommer d'autres
donc ça fait des années que ceci se
passe l'autre chose aussi qui est
important il faut dire ce qui souffre le
plus par rapport à la pandémie ducobu 19
c'est justement cette communauté la
african american parce qu'ils vivent
dans des quartiers délabrés dans la
pauvreté et c'est cela qui fait et
finalement ils sont la majorité des
femmes et des plus ils sont présentement
donc c'est important ce que vous parce
que vous êtes également des nues
on l'a sous-estimé dans cette crise là
est-ce que ça n'exacerbe pas l'humeur
des gens
évidemment plus ample et évidemment des
gens semblent j'ai parlé avec une
infirmière noir la 27e puis probablement
elle manifeste présente à new york lui
si metz une infirmière dans un hôpital
du blanc que dit on nous laisse à numa
et même les gouvernements nous est
propre
qu'imaginez-vous là c'est la situation
réelle sur le terrain et puis qui subit
ça c'est surtout les plus pauvres donc
les africains américains
les collègues qui sont des latine est
que ces jeunes blancs moussis qui
veulent les soutenir avec sa faim
finalement un corps de la population
jeune
j'ai oublié ça madame bougies ces puces
ceux qui connaissent jesse jackson puis
martin luther king sassi finissent dans
leur tête à recy aujourd'hui et
maintenant et on peut dire ces jeunes
sont en 35,1 en descendant donc je
regarde en même temps tôt quelqu'un une
jeune femme à new york depuis l'âge de
15 ans que je fais des manifestations
d'aujourd'hui gerin et à écouter leurs
c'est sans cette génération de la coupe
dans la rue puis quelques oreilles en
plus pour finir est monsieur jobs que
monsieur 30 ne veut pas régler la crise
il veut a augmenté la crise pourquoi
parce que le ministre le gouvernement
s'interrogeait au mini a rappelé le
maire et des mots qu'a donc il va se
servir de ça pour montrer à la
population surtout ceux qui vont voter
pour lui vous voyez les démocrates ne
savent pas comment régler ce problème là
moi je vais les règles et donc vous
croyez qu'il va utiliser cette crise-là
en vue de cette élection présidentielle
et c'est pour ce qu'ils ont à faire le
gouverneur de l'état 1 puis le maire de
la ville d'envoyer la police militaire
il la rejette oui mais la police
militaire soviétique sont spécialisés
justement dans la question des émeutes
donc mais le gouverneur a dit non je
n'ai pas besoin je me voilà que ça prend
l'approbation quand même du coup ben
ammar le gouverneur suit la constitution
de l'état du minnesota et pour l'instant
c'est lui qui gère son propre record
mais
monsieur tron est malade tout à fait de
voir la police militaire envoyé par une
huile à bord pour prouver que lui
capable de régler le problème quand
juste les démocrates sont en charge de
cet état ne peuvent pas le faire et
c'est un peu ça fait partie de tout ça
c'est tj électoral de se servir même la
pandémie amplement la chine angloma
n'importe qui sauf lui ou s'il n'y pas
de stratégie tout le monde lady qui
n'écoute même pas les scientifiques aux
états unis ah ça c'est un autre sujet
non actuellement ça fait partie de la
même chose vous avez raison s'est
affaissé je sais c'est toutes les
contradictions qui existent aux états
unis depuis une quarantaine d'années
depuis devenu au pouvoir de rodrigues et
puisque c'est l'état on va devoir se
laisser là dessus mais je pense qu'on va
se reparler très certainement bientôt
puisque ce n'est pas terminé
malheureusement cette situation la quête
explose je n'ai pas terminé ses jeux pas
voir donald au revoir au revoir au
revoir dès jeudi